one and you are live
chairman thank you very much uh
good evening members colleagues uh any
members of the public
listening uh welcome to this central
area planning committee
meeting on wednesday the 4th of november
2020 my name is councillor mark hurd and
i'm the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which come into effect on
the 4th of april in response to the
kobit 19
situation and there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present at this
meeting to ensure your microphone
remains muted and your video feed off
we're not addressing the committee this
will reduce
background noises and avoid any
unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and is being uh and by
being present in the meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function in the
meeting
to indicate you wish to speak i will
then invite
you to speak at the appropriate time
members are reminded
that apart from indicating you wish to
speak or that you have to leave the
meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions
or any other purpose members when
speaking
and referring to the agenda papers
please reference
a page or paragraph number and keep your
contributions
as clear and concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure also
that you turn on your microphone
and video now if i may ask officers
taking part in the meeting to introduce
themselves
starting with mr lee
good evening members i am matthew lee
lead specialist place and chief planning
officer at morton district council
thank you thank you and uh michael
johnson
thank you chairman members my name is
michael johnson
i'm the lead specialist development
management thank you
thank you michael annie keane
thank you chairman i'm annie keane
senior caseworker development management
thank you very much and kate
good afternoon chairman my name is katie
fuller i'm clark this evening's
committee
thank you very much um i think i saw
another officer in there somewhere
any other officers present
okay kate please can you know carry out
can you now carry out a roll call of
members to confirm who is in attendance
thank you
yes chairman members i will call your
name in alphabetical order
please could you indicate if you are
present starting with
counselor beal yep
president thank you councillor edwards
present thank you
councillor heard present
thank you councillor lagan
evening members everybody i'm certainly
here
thank you councillor mays
president good evening thank you
councillor morris good evening everybody
thank you councillor none
yes here katie good evening everyone
thank you councillor seanacy oh here
katie thank you
thank you councillor stilts
good evening present thank you and
councillor swain
yes president thank you
that's all chairman thank you very much
um
are there any other um counsellors in
attendance please
okay and any other officers in
attendance that haven't been mentioned
okay thank you very much uh gender item
number two is apologies
for absence uh may i have the apologies
for absence please kate
uh we've had no apologies for absence
thank you we have a full house okay
thank you very much
uh gender item number three are minutes
from the 9th of uh september 2020
it's recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 9th of september
which are found on pages 7 to 14 are
approved
as a true and accurate record
iso move if you wish to second that
motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now please
counselor none seconded thank you
councillor none if any member wishes to
raise any matter of accuracy
please use the chat function to indicate
and i will ask you to speak
uh kate can you advise if any member has
indicated a wish to speak
no member has indicated thank you very
much
okay we'll uh we'll now take the vote i
can do this uh in alphabetical order
uh or do you wish to agree by ascent
agreed agreed
agreed that's great okay thank you very
much indeed
members agenda item number four is
declarations of interest this is to
disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business
in the agenda having regard to
paragraphs
six to eight inclusive the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should they
need a right throughout the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat function now to
indicate
and i will invite you to speak
now i see that there are quite a few
there
um obviously this
application uh is in relation to um
uh has been called in because it's in
relation to a member of staff and i
think it
uh will probably be taken as read that
most members are declaring because of
that
i certainly will because i know the
applicant
kate are there any other members who
wish to declare
yes we have councillor none councillor
lagan and councillor stilts
okay and councillor mays
uh councillor none thank you very much
chairman uh item
five uh i'm acquainted with the
applicant non-pecuniary
yes uh yeah non-procurement for me as
well thank you councillor lagan
yeah thanks mark yeah just uh
non-pecuniary and
i undeclare it just out of transparency
that i'm aware of
annie keane from years ago when we used
to train at the same martial arts club
thank you thank you very much councillor
stilts
thank you mr chairman um like you and
councillor none
um nonpacunary and i'm acquainted with
the applicant
thank you very much and councillor maize
non-pecuniary are um
um item five as i know the applicant
thank you and uh council shawnee
you're still meeting yes thank you
non-pecuniary
um as i do know the applicant thank you
okay and i think that's really the
reason that uh this has
uh has come to us uh councillor morris
good evening
councilor maurice you're still muted
sorry chair struggling with the buttons
uh
would it not be an idea just to put into
the minutes that um
all the counsellors here would have a
non-pecuniary interest
uh due to the uh applicant being a
member of staff
yes i think that's uh i think that's uh
not an unfair thing to say
i mean some people do know uh some
people do know
uh mr ellen and some do not um but
if you do it is down to the individual
to uh to make that declaration
thank you in that case just like to say
non-pecuniary interest i've spoken to
the fella a couple of times
okay thank you very much indeed
thank you very much okay so we'll move
on then
to the application itself agenda item
number five this is uh
two zero
two zero slash double o eight two
four slash house uh 46 wentworth meadows
more than essex
cn96ej so we moved to this agenda item
it's found on pages 15 to 24
members please note that a member's
update in relation to this application
has also been circulated prior to the
meeting
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present
this item remember as a reminder that if
you wish to speak on this item please
make this known by using the chat
function within the meeting i will then
come to you in turn please make
your points clear and succinct
ms king could you please present the
report please
could i just uh pause you there
councillor morris
sorry uh chair i've put that in for
after the report
if i speak up thank you very much uh
okay annie carry on
thank you chair
planning permission is sought for the
construction of a first floor side
extension
over the existing garage
this is the location plan showing the
location of the site
and the position of the amenity space of
number 45 saint peter's avenue to the
south
east
this is the block plan showing the
position of the proposed extension
and the distances from the rear of
number 45 saint peters avenue to the
proposed development
this is the existing ground floor plan
the existing first floor plan
the proposed ground floor plan
and the proposed first floor plan
these are the existing front and rear
elevations
and the existing western and eastern
elevations
these are the proposed front and rear
elevations showing the location of the
first floor
side extension
and these are proposed eastern and
western elevations
again showing the proposed extension
this application is a resubmission of a
previously refused scheme
which was heard at committee on the 15th
july for a first floor side extension
and a part single story part 2 story
rear extension
these are the previously proposed
elevations
these are the pictures of the site
whilst this application has been reduced
in scale from the previously refused
scheme
removing the rear extensions it is
considered this application has not
overcome
all of the previous reasons for refusal
the application is therefore
recommended for refusal due to the scale
and design of the first floor side
extension
which would result in a large dominant
bulky addition
particularly due to the depth and width
of the first floor side projection
this also refused due to close proximity
of the development to the boundary of
the neighbouring dwelling to the south
west which number 45 peters avenue
resulting in an overbearing form of
development
thank you chairman
thank you very much ms keane now under
the council's public participation
scheme we have
received one submission from the
applicant
and in line with the public
participation scheme
i've reviewed the submission and an
officer will now read
this out and we're allocating only two
minutes for the reading of this
submission in accordance with the scheme
mr johnson are you able to read this
submission please
yes thank you chair
submission from jack ellum the applicant
dear members thank you for your decision
notice on my application
and the feedback included i have sought
to address the concerns raised by the
officer
and members of the committee you will
note
the rear elements have been removed
resulting in no loss
of my private garden this also
significantly reduces the scale design
and envisaged dominance
of the development on all neighbors the
depth of the extension
over the garage has also been slightly
reduced
denoting the extension subservient to
the current dwelling
as previously demonstrated the proposed
extension
has the support of all neighbors and it
is my hope
this revised proposal meets with your
approval
thank you chairman um thank you michael
uh now in a moment i will be moving this
recommendation
um in order that we can debate it but i
will refer
to any other officers before i do move
to that
are there any other officers wishing to
speak
not at this time sharing that okay thank
you very much so the recommendation as
set out within the report is as follows
uh that the planning application uh 2824
house 46 went with meadows more than
essex
uh be refused for the reasons as
detailed in section 8
of this report if any member wishes to
second that motion
please turn on your video unmute your
microphone
and state your name now other
members will be given an opportunity to
speak uh
councillor none seconded
thank you very much for that i will now
invite members
to make any comments on the report
katie can you advise me of any members
who wish to speak please mr chairman we
have
councillor nun councillor morris and
councillor swain
thank you very much i'll take them in
that order then council and none
um thank you very much chairman um could
i ask the officers please
whether the applicant sought any
pre-planning advice
for this second submission
thank you chairman i'll comment
while not formal pre-application some
discussions did take place with the
applicant following the refusal of the
last application
the various issues were discussed um
the applicant can question whether uh
any reduction of some form that could
both meet
his needs and satisfy the concerns of
over dominance
and overbearingness could be considered
um
officers were not able to say that it
would have any significant difference
but the scheme had been amended
accordingly thank you chairman
um through the chair could i just come
back on that please
yes um thank you michael
for that um response is is this
when you say no formal pre-planning
advice
um is this kind of discussion this kind
of advice
something that would be open to members
of the public then
three chairman picked this up sorry oh
sorry michael you know you're happy too
yeah
no um yeah this this um it's it's not
uncommon for
sometimes officers to get a call from an
applicant um
no advice was given no direction
in terms of what would be acceptable or
not
there were no plans tabled uh
for us well me in this particular
respect to consider
it was literally a a chat that the
that the applicant would be revising the
scheme
no advice was given no advice could be
given because in offices view
um any any
any amendment to the scheme that would
be significant one would have to be
formalized and two clearly wouldn't meet
the applicant's needs
okay thank you very much chairman thank
you michael
through your champ can i just make it
clear i think my question is trying to
make it
abundantly clear both to the members and
any members of public viewing that
you know as members of the committee we
know we've you've heard me say a hundred
times we're quite happy to give some
informal comments on an application
after refusal but
the council's policy is that any proper
consultation
through the pre-application process is a
paid service um
but quite often that advice the informal
advice is that
it may not be beneficial to enter a
formal pre-application advice because
the points
where officers are or the council is and
where the applicant are
are so far apart that there would not be
any real betterment than what the
officers report
clearly lays down but yeah for clarity
that it's just a general process that
the
lpa does thank you chairman thank you
chairman
grateful to mr lee thank you thank you
very much uh councillor morris
sorry chair i seem to have some sticky
buttons tonight
um i'd just like to say that uh after
looking through this i was in favor of
the uh first application
um i've uh i've noticed that it is um
d1 uh dominant overbearing
demonstrable blah blah blah i believe
that the
applicant has um successfully um
overcome these problems and if um
if i can i'd like to propose that we um
give this permission
and you know let the guy do it because
he seems to have
ticked all the boxes now i believe that
day one
is a it's a perspective and
there are no objections from any of the
neighbors the
town councils are pro have recommended
its approval
um so i'd like to propose that we allow
this one
thank you thank you i i have noted your
proposal uh i will call for a second uh
but i don't want to stifle debate
at this stage i just want to give
officers an opportunity uh to speak
okay thank you very much uh the next
speaker is
councillor swain
thank you chairman um yes as i recall
when the previous um
application came up the main concern
actually
um and reason for um the committee
projecting it was the loss of immunity
space and that
seems to have been dealt with um on the
parking
um i think the officers seem to be happy
with the situation
although i would um like to point out
that the additional space
involved in this extension produces two
rather small rooms and to think of it
um i to think of the whole development
as a five-bedroom house i think
um and relate that to parking spaces is
perhaps
um not entirely um appropriate
there will be quite small bedroom
sizes uh in fact they don't need to be
bedrooms
and we have bedrooms which are actually
computer rooms or something quite
different
um i wanted to just check that the
window
at the back of this development is that
a clear window
or um frosted in any way
um having said that i'm not
um i don't go along with the argument
about overlooking
um on the neighboring property um
it's to the side and having looked at
the um
how the extension would look
i think the the change in the roof line
makes it far less um uh what you say
um dominant on the um the local scene
um and therefore i can't see
any objection to this um particular
application
and and would support it
thank you very much before i ask for any
more speakers uh
miss keen are you able to tell us if
this window is frosted
please
uh yes chair um the window as far as i'm
aware is not
to be frosted okay thank you very much
um so i just want to just wanted to
clarify as well that there is
there is no overlooking uh reasons
um for concern in the reason for refusal
okay thank you mr johnson um kate i'm
pretty sure we've got some other
speakers
i have got some names here but uh can
you just confirm which ones they are
please
uh yes councilman i heard we have
councillor lagan
councillor shauna c and councillor bill
i'm pleased to say that matches my list
thank you very much
uh councillor lagan
thank you chair um so just to clarify
a couple of the things that were said i
think mr johnson said that
mr bob jack he said he had the support
of all the neighbors um
michael would you mind just confirming
that again mr johnson
uh you're still muted
apologies for that um yes the um
the presentation well the the commentary
from the applicant was that he had the
support
of the neighbours
thank you very much thanks
um through the chair as well um this
house is quite interesting
this whole road isn't it considering why
it was actually built and what it's
built for
and that the design of the houses are
rather unique because
we used to call them the wonky houses
when i was a kid because the
the roof line is slightly different so
the the d1
bulk and scale is subjective and i find
myself
liking like my colleagues um with the
support of the neighbors
and with the work that jack's actually
done to reduce it and
maintaining the immunity space at the
back which was a concern i
i'm like to support the application
but but i appreciate the office of just
confirming those questions i had
thank you thank you very much mr lee
thank you chairman um do you um just
wanted to make a point in relation to
planning law
and case law in relation to support life
support popularity
etc in relation to a planning
application
um the lack or the number of support
for a planning application shouldn't
particularly weigh
members views when coming to termination
of planning application
um a lack of objections should not be
assumed
uh to be that people in favor and
actually the fact that whether people
are in favor or not is not a
consideration
um that's a number of different pieces
of case sort of summed up together
but one of the probably the most
important one and i'm not quoting
verbatim to uh
summing up is that where the actual
inspector says that
the public rely on the decision maker to
make correct decisions when determining
a planning application
um it maybe they don't want to argue
with their name but it may be that they
don't underesti
they don't understand the impact on the
development or it may just be that
they are assuming that the council will
make the correct decision
so while we know comments from the
applicant and we know
the lack of any substantial objections
from
neighbours this should not be a reason
to ignore the potential impact on
neighbours
that is what the case law is and members
need to be conscious that
this was a key part of the reason for
refusal last time
that this committee refused to scheme
while there was concerns in relation to
the impact of the loss of
amenity space that wasn't the sole
reason so i think um
probably best if ms king can just show
members the two schemes
to show the differences in relation to
impacts and neighbors just so that they
can
fully assess that and whether the
variations do
meet the concerns or overcome the
concerns that they raised
raised previously but i just obviously
want to make members
minds clear on the value that they
should be giving
to any neighbor responses and also
just make it clear that they're clearly
able to delineate the differences when
determining this
application thank you chairman if you do
that ms keene that'd be great
thank you very much ms kings are you
able to do that
thank you chad put you on the spot sorry
if i share my screen
so this is the proposed elevations and
you can see how high up the roof
line it comes um and then if i
also say adjacent to the boundaries as
well obviously it's in close proximity
in the height
there is obviously yeah yeah so this is
the
proposed elevations and you can see it
comes halfway up
the roof soap on this side and the
previously refused scheme comes to
a similar position um if i skip
back
so this block plan shows
the distance from the back of number 45
to where the proposed extension
will be you can see it's a only a 10
meter stretch
so it would still
have some form of impact on that
neighbor
even though it's it's been reduced by
half a meter
thank you chair thank you very much
annie
um councillor shauna c is next
uh thank you chairman um yes um i've
read through this thoroughly and i've
looked at all the plans
and on 5.4.2
and also it's borne out by the proposed
first floor plan um
i think it's a three bedroom going to a
four bedroom
because the original third bedroom is
being made into a shower room
uh have any offices got a comment on
that please
uh mr lee
i think ms kims can show the plans we
can confirm oh sorry
um annie can you help us out on that
yeah so it would be a four bedroom
four bedroom and a shower that looks
good
that's correct okay thank you thank you
very much chairman
thank you councillor shaw honestly and
uh
councillor bill did you have did you
want to speak
as always chairman thank you um
sorry i don't know how to use the chat
that's why i stuck me a little bit
it's okay um also it i was gonna quote
um from a previous thing it's like page
23 whatever but i'll keep it simple
if you look at item a reason for refusal
if you look at it it says result in just
demonstrable harm
character appearance locality quad
contrary
to policies d1 of the local development
plan
if you look at 5.5.2
it says whatever all of that paragraph
based on this it is considered the
application has overcome the previous
reason for refusal based on the level of
immunity space
the proposal is therefore in accordance
with policy d1 so that's contradictory
okay i think i think i could reply to
that but i might leave it to an officer
mr lee
no counselor chairman i'm more than
happy for you to
reply okay well i i think the immunity
space
uh was was a separate item the the
reason for a refusal was the the fact
that it was overbearing and i think
i think although it's just under the
minimum of
uh the immunity space i think it's about
five
less than it should be and that wasn't
felt to have the difference but the
reason for refusal was
the uh the fact that it was uh
overbearing
would that be right mr lee yeah thank
you jim that is
accurate but just for a point of clarity
just for a little bit more information
policy d1
which is entitled design quality and
built environment has
um well it says all development must and
then there's
the first point which is respect to
enhance the character and local context
and making a positive contribution in
terms of
and then there are seven points under
that and then there are another
nine points as well so just because the
development is able to meet one aspect
of the requirements of d1
doesn't mean it can meet all of the
requirements
um and that's what happens quite often
um a scheme may have issues in relation
to design
such as we you know if you look back at
the last application there was an
assimilation design
and an issue in relation to impact on
neighbours and an issue on
in relation to impact on the amenity
space so
that's one application previously fell
foul on three different points basically
within d1
obviously this application has come
forward removing the rear garden
so there's no impact on the immune space
so that aspect of that proposal that
conflicted with d1 is no longer present
that doesn't mean that all of the other
points within d1 have automatically been
met
and that's the point that d1 is a quite
a broad and multi-limbed
policy thank you chairman can i come
back on that chair thank you very much
yes yes it's just a quick one because
that's all i can manage these days
um i think i would like matt um
to basically send us an email with what
all of the
policies actually mean i don't think
i've ever seen
a full d1 or whatever so that would be
really helpful to actually have a list
of all of the uh
policies relating to the ldp
is that possible through you chairman i
can get the
link to the ldp circulated to members i
think that would be yeah
that would be a nice thing for uh for
all then probably all councillors but
certainly all members of this committee
yes please okay thank you chairman thank
you very much
um i think there are a couple of more
speakers who uh i know council person
you've spoken once before i will come
back to you
katie is there another speaker is it do
i see councillor maze
uh yes councillor mace councilmance go
ahead
uh yeah um thank you miss kitten could
you
put up the um elevation that basically
you would see
from the neighbor's house in i think
it's some
peter's road
are you able to do that ah
um so on can i just ask on this side
wall
if i lived at some peter's road i would
just look at
a blank wall of approximately five point
six meters is that right
it's not not i'm sorry are you going to
ask that annie
yeah miss kane i'm sorry through your
chair um
yes there are no windows in that
elevation so it would be a blank wall
okay um and from just wanted to clarify
that it's actually not a five meter high
blank wall
um up to the eaves which is which is the
break point
um to where it says the garage and
extension wall and the extension roof
um it's uh 3.9 meters high
and then the uh roof hips back
towards the main roof where you will
have the tiled element
that's right just keep clear yes
thank you mr johnson can you um tell me
how high the existing garage is
um in relation to this proposed
elevation
so how much higher is it than what we're
looking at
mr johnson and if you if you can comment
on that
by looking at the existing plans mr
doesn't i don't think it has the
measurements on it three check
no i don't have the measurements on the
existing
um so um i think annie if you to take a
few minutes you can probably
go out of this and look it up aren't you
on uniform if
on civica so yeah come back to that in a
couple of minutes if you can give us a
couple of minutes councilman
we'll look it up for you yes thank you i
think what i think the
the point that i'm trying to ascertain
is um we're going from
looking at um a low roof or no roof
to actually maybe three meters
um above what is existing and it being a
blank wall
um i'm not sure that as a neighbor i
would want to look at that
or i would um yeah i'd be happy
from a design perspective to to be
looking at something like that so i i
just wanted to
to know what sort of height we were
looking at um
you know looking out of a window of your
of your house which you'd look at every
single day
as a neighbor and it's not just the
neighbor that goes directly onto
that particular property it's also that
probably the next two neighbors down
that would also be looking out on that
on that blank wall so although it looks
okay i think from the front perspective
i'm not particularly happy with it
from a neighboring perspective and we
have to remember i think as somebody did
say
that those neighbors may not be there in
a year's time
or three years time so we do have to
think forward
um as to what um and that might affect
house prices and stuff like that i know
that's not necessarily a material
consideration but it is something that
we have to think from a design
perspective
i'm just not wholly happy with it all
right
thank you very much did you want to
check the comment chairman yep
firstly i'd just you know basically say
that counselor maze for the first 90
of what she said pretty much was summing
up the section that is the officer's
you know concerns yeah as in hit the now
on the head in relation to what officers
are raising concerns on the impact of
the neighbor of your
unable former development for one of a
better phrase but i would just obviously
as she did say but just reiterate for
all members that house price is an
impact on house prices either positive
or negative
he's not a material consideration for
planning and i know councillor may has
acknowledged that but just
but just in case any members didn't pick
up on that please do not take that into
consideration
but the rest of it is what she was
saying is basically what forms part of
the reason for refusal
and is the officers um within the
officers republic thank you chairman
thank you very much thank you councillor
mays um i i mean i'm conscious of the
fact that we have had a proposal by
councillor morris which was duly
seconded by
council of bill uh councillor swainer
you can come back one more
time if you if it's not been mentioned
before please
you know just on that last point that
has been made obviously
most from the design
the drawings um half of the increase in
elevation will be a sloping roof
um rather than a blank wall um
i think the way the rooms are going to
be used is
is irrelevant but the main point i
wanted to point out when you look at the
street scene is
that this is a rather individual
property
um because of its location it's not
like not um should we say affecting the
street scene in the way that it would if
it was part of a
whole street thank you
thank you very much um councillor stilts
you haven't had the opportunity to speak
on this i
i know you want to speak as well cancer
legend but councillor stilts first
thing thank you mr chairman um we do
actually
have the approved local development plan
booklet that we were all given that
gives you what policy d1
is and lays them all out um
from what i was looking at from this
last thing it is right against the
boundary wall so basically
from the boundary wall up you're going
to see a blank wall and like councillor
maze
i wouldn't be happy with looking at a
completely blank wall from my
garden or from my house i take it that
the windows of the bungalow
look out towards this blank wall the
other point
is that i seem to be a bit confused we
now seem to have two proposals
on the table because didn't you propose
and wasn't it seconded the officer's
recommendation first
uh i think we i think we uh
yeah that was correct i think that's
correct yeah we'll have to go with the
first
with the first one um first yes
uh councillor lagan you uh you you have
a final question i hope
no oh no i've got hours to go yeah did
chair no
all it was is thanks um just um
gillette's answering my questions i was
just a bit confused because we already
had a proposal but that's all done so
i'm built up
and and get on with the voting thanks
thank you very much
okay uh sorry sorry chairman uh just for
clarification
uh you still wanted to have the height
of the
existing wall under the boundary from
miss keane
yes please yeah do do you have that
information
through your chair yes so the
existing eaves would be 2.7
meters and the ridge height higher
than the no the existing eaves are one
1.4 meters higher than
uh the proposed e sorry a 1.4 meters
higher than the existing
and the proposed ridge height would be
2.9 meters higher
than the existing okay yeah
i i think that's too much thank you
thank you thank you chair
thank you very much so i think that has
been
well debated uh i'm now going to
move to the vote so the initial
recommendation
which indeed i moved and this was
seconded by
council of nun uh is that this is
refused so that was the first proposal
if that fails we move on to the second
so katie could ask you to take the roll
call please
yes chairman um so we are voting to
refuse the application as per
the officer's recommendation members
i'll take your name in alphabetical
order please could you indicate
whether you are fought against or
abstaining from the vote
starting with councillor miss bill
please against
thank you councillor
four councillor heard
uh i'll abstain thank you
councillor
against please thank you
councillor mays
four thank you councillor morris
against councillor none
four thank you councillor shawnee
against you councillor stilts
four thank you and councillor swain
again thank you
chairman that is four four
five against and one abstention
so that uh so that fails
so uh in that case we'll move on to the
second uh proposal which was uh council
morris julie seconded um
by councillor beale uh that this is
approved could we take the roll call
councillor heard before we can take the
right or do a vote that need the
reason for approval from uh councillor
morris
for his proposal obviously in that needs
to talk to the
proposed reason for refusal thank you
chairman thank you yes councillor morris
do you have a reason for refusal
benefits outweigh the harm i believe the
benefits outweigh the harm
through chairman um through the debate
there have been no benefits of the
proposal highlighted
um the only benefits i could see from
this proposal would relate to an
individual and planning does not unless
it's very special circumstances which
there
have been none put forward by the
applicant and none discussed at this
uh committee that i my advice would be
that'll be a very flawed reason for
approval
thank you chairman it can't uh miss
keynes worth putting up the
reason for views or if you if you can
just so members can see it
yes please
sorry i don't know it's a hand um i'm
sick
so if not i should be able to put it up
you could do mr johnson mr johnson thank
you
let me zoom in a little bit on that
please
perfect okay thank you very much
so the reason is that it would by reason
of its
scaling design would result in a large
dominant and bulky addition
uh secondly that by virtue of the
of its depth height and proximity to the
boundary
would result in an overbearing impact
through youtube if we uh
were to go to 5.2.6
um it does now overcome the reasons for
refusal
uh previously in the previous
application
so i would say that it
uh should be approved as it's overcome
the uh previous reasons for refusal i'd
also say
that um policies d1
are a perspective and in my in my
opinion my from my perspective
i believe that the benefits outweigh the
harm i don't believe there's
any objections um from any of the
neighbors
i understand what mr lee is saying about
their may doing
in the future but we can only deal with
the um
application as it stands now and on its
own merits
so i would say that this application has
um overcome the reasons for refusal
previously
mr lee is that okay um
obviously councilmember's reference
paragraph was it 5.3 can
johnson can we just go up to that is
that possible
i believe it was 5.2.6
oh sorry i apologize i'll let you off
this time matt
thanks appreciate it um
again i'll do my best
case of sleep i think that's quoting the
reason for a refusal isn't it well yeah
they can't have to shoot straight
up between obviously highlights that um
the only issue i've got or
slightly i've got with the councillor
most uh
reason for probably it's twofold firstly
the
partly he said there is no harm and then
he's saying the benefits outweigh the
harm so there is
quite conflicting and then secondly as
i've stated
there are no apparent benefits there has
been no debate around any benefits of
this scheme
um you know obviously if this was
an enabling development allowing 10
houses so you can provide funding for
a list of buildings to be developed
there it's all that would be outside the
center boundary and conscious policies
you might argue that the benefits
outweigh the harm
we haven't discussed any benefits in
planning terms as part of
tonight as part of this committee and as
i would say is that
once again in reiterate any benefits are
solely to the applicant
and personal benefits are not something
we should be looking at
as a reason for approval unless they're
classed as very special circumstances
which is a something defined through
case law and the applicant has not put
forward any
very special circumstances that i'm
aware of and i'd ask either mr johnson
or ms king just to confirm that i
haven't
i've not overlooked something thank
chairman yeah just before we uh
before we do we do that um i think that
uh i have heard that uh this was
uh a subjective matter
if in the opinion of the committee
that it is not um overbearing in its
scale design and height
is that a sufficient reason
do you chairman yet obviously it's a
subjective matter the impact on the
neighbors it's not something we can
definitively state such as car parking
spaces or amenity space
um and jason said yeah if members
consider that the amendments proposed
have overcome the previous reasons for
refusal in relation to design
and impact on neighbours that would be
something it's just for clarity
obviously
just when we make statements obviously
conflict or when we say benefits
outweigh harm
just need to obviously be clear but
obviously when it comes to a subjective
point
that's in the gift of the members or
decision makers which in this case is
the members
thank you thank you
i have had several members um asked to
speak again
uh mr johnson yep sorry
i was just going to say if to hopefully
help move this on
the uh the following paragraph may be
where members can glean some support
um for their reasons in um in
in in supporting this application and as
mr lee just mentioned
um it discusses the amendments um
you know the proposed ridgeline of the
roof been lowered
uh by half a meter um the pitch of the
roof has been made parallel so there are
some
amendments um where we are going
um against following a resubmission of a
previously refused scheme
and there have been some material
amendments
the i suppose subjectiveness that one
may
bring to the debate is to what degree do
you feel
that the amendment from a design point
of view
overcomes the reasons for refusal and i
think it's in in
2.5.2.7 which is where members can find
support yes um okay yes i
i understand that so what you're saying
is the
with the the amended application which
has uh removed the
the rear extension lowered the uh
the roof line um would make
a difference subjectively
well in members opinion imam's opinion
obviously
refusal argument
okay without wishing to lead you
councillor morris
uh are you satisfied with that
um i'd just like to point out that
any benefits would outweigh any harms
and the way i see this application
it hasn't got a lot of benefits but it
also doesn't cause a lot of plan
um i'd just state that by
increasing a house uh a house is size
and therefore
not forcing an owner to go and buy a new
build which
we haven't got the infrastructure for
that could be
the you know the sole benefit that would
outweigh any harm
and as there's been no objections
whatsoever
i don't see that there's any harm either
so
i do think it's a perspective point of
view where
um there are not a lot of benefits but
there are
also practically no harms
and so therefore i do believe that you
know we should be allowing this
i i'm not sure that's a that's a
planning reason uh mr lee did you want
to speak on that
day chairman i think you've just covered
it you know the fact that you're not
forcing one of a better word someone to
move is
not something there's a material
situation to be given weight and
planning
decision making process unfortunately
planning is quite heartless in that
respect
thank you chairman okay um councillor
swain you wanted to come back
i really want to move this along really
well
one way of putting it is to say that um
we believe the um
previous um reasons for refusal have
been
overcome and the revised application
is consistent with policies d1 and h4
with the ldp
i think that um i think that might cover
it mr lee
yep thank you chairman that's obviously
yeah fine
okay thank you very much so we have got
uh we've got that
reason for refusal uh
i've got councillor lagan and
shaughnessy wishing to speak again so
councillor lagan if you could be concise
please
yeah don't worry mark i just i just
wanted to add maybe
to to strengthen it with councillor
morris's permission
to look in policy d1 where it talks
about respecting enhance the character
you know it does meet um policy b1a in
its architectural style because it fits
in with the
with the with the design of the area and
as detailed design features innovative
designer construction solutions
are innovative and also number eight it
also
contributes to and enhances the local
distinctiveness
because it will be distinctive in a very
distinctive area
this considerations to put in to try and
help strengthen
acceptance
um thank you councillor yeah um that
sounds uh
very funky so uh if you'd like to put
that in as an amendment maybe
i'll be happy with that thank you cancel
councillor councillor shawna so you
wanted to speak
um yes thank you chairman for allowing
me to come back
um concerning um
other members and comments about the um
neighbours on saint peter's avenue
looking at a blank wall
and they do actually look at a blank
wall at the moment orbit a little
further away from them
um but they're not looking at anything
beautiful at the moment um it is
subjective
i i actually think um that
um with the material amendments those
small amendments
i actually think this is um quite a nice
looking
extension
um it is subjective i i actually
think that with the material amendments
those
small amendments i actually think this
is
quite a nice
right okay i think i think we uh we got
the gist of that thank you very much
indeed yes thank you i was out of sync
there chairman
for whatever reason thank you thank you
very much
so we've had uh we've had the reason for
refusal
so now i will go to the second proposal
of councillor morris
which was seconded by councillor beale
to approve
this um katie could we take the vote
again please
um yes chairman um so we are voting
to approve the application contrary to
the officer's
recommendation which was seconded by
councillor bill to approve this
um katie could we take the vote against
him members i will take your name in
alphabetical order
please could you indicate whether you
are for against or abstaining
starting with councillor miss bill
please so we are voting
to approve why are we getting an echo
here
um i'm four obviously because i have
seconded it but i did have my hand up
and did i didn't get
no one came to me um but basically
uh councillor maze was worried about the
wall um but
i presume there's gonna be a two meter
fence
by that so they're not gonna probably
see about a meter of wall
but i'm for four thank you
thank you councillor edwards
having listened to the argument i'm
going to vote for
thank you thank you councillor herd
isle of stein thank you
councillor
paul please katie thank you councillor
mays
against you councillor morris
obviously four thank you thank you
councillor none
against thank you councillor seancey
katie thank you thank you councillor
stilts
against thank you and
councillor swain paul
thank you chairman that is six
four three against and one abstention
thank you katie in that case that is
approved three chairman obviously
suggested conditions um
which i would advise members
are the time plans uh
materials standard three also i'd
advised the pd
rights are removed in relation to
um the uh
window installation of windows in that
elevation so they can't
call it can't be put in the future to
cause any overlooking
um and i think that would be unless mr
johnson
was keen i've got any suggestions
okay anything else miss kane
um no i think that's fine thank you
thank you very much um we'll move on
then to
agenda item number six any other items
of business that
the chairman of the committee decides
are urgent
the only thing that i would say members
that this is our last meeting before the
statutory annual meeting tomorrow night
we have had 24 scheduled meetings
since may 19 and we have sat
12 times to consider applications
13 of which have been approved 14 have
been
refused uh i'd like to offer my thanks
for your attendance and patience during
this very difficult period
it's been a great honour to chair this
committee and i sincerely hope the next
chairman
also enjoys the support of all members
i also note and thank our hard-working
officers
who often end up in the line of fire and
my great thanks also to the clerks
whose work i will never underestimate
and they really do
make things run smoothly so thank you
all
and i will close this meeting
uh in the municipal this municipal year
at uh pm